I am a 22 year old with degree car
security and the availability of more
sex and more power than I need now I
have only to explain to myself what it
all means if you look at the history of
humanity you'll find the search for
meaning everywhere from ancient Greeks
to India to China wherever somehow it is
caped the attention of the psychologist
and psychiatrist Pia in frontof stood up
and said look I mean let's look at the
obvious people are looking not only for
something - despite functions before
they want to know they want to
understand therefore there's art
literature Religion Whatever them some
time to time in psychiatry an individual
appears who seems the challenge our
concepts regarding the nature of man his
goals his behavior and the ways in which
he can be helped
such a man is dr. victory Frankel dr.
Frankel medical doctor and visiting
lecturer at Harvard his author of the
famous book man's search for meaning his
father mother brother and wife all died
in Nazi concentration camps or gas
chambers he himself as a survivor of the
terrible camp at ostrich the experience
of inhumanity has never been probably
expressed consistently more intensely
than it was for the Jews in World War
two and for Amanda experience that and
still not lose sight of what what makes
us human the spirit of what it is to be
a human and the ability to find meaning
and the importance of meaning in any
variant of life but there is an
empowering meaning available to us that
there's always that choice emotional
things about it
logotherapy is the name of the new
psychiatrist dr. Frank Frankel is
talking about now this means that you
have found the meaning of the meaning to
life we psychiatrists are not omniscient
we are out to help our patients to
rediscover the meaning in life there
were two psychiatrists in history that I
know of that were not about money
dr. Viktor Frankl and dr. Milton
Erickson you're not dare to pay
thousands of dollars for them and keep
them coming back for collector therapy
for years dr. Frankel was the
quintessential brief therapist
[Music]
you